pressure is building on policymakers to
plug some of the loop holes allowing
multinational corporations to dodge tax
taxation is it jealously guarded member
state competence but now following
revelations of favorable tax
arrangements in many member states mep s
want reform there are some very radical
measures in there if there was a common
consolidated corporate tax base across
europe that would mean the same
definitions of what's taxable across
europe still up to member states to
decide whether they want to tax those
things and how much they want to tax
them by but at least the definitions
would be the same key targets include
country-by-country reporting by
multinationals of their tax details
member states reporting on changes to
their special tax rulings defining what
constitutes a tax haven and
whistleblower protection this is not so
much about the issue eva should be
country-by-country reporting if there
should be dealing with the takes havens
or supporting the visible activity but
the issue is how and i guess we were
able to find a decent compromises if as
expected any peace initiative is
supported by the full house the
Commission will be obliged to produce
legislation within three months or to
explain why not